As things stand right now,
the app's templates are just
displaying static HTML.
So no matter which menu item we view,
we always get the same one.
If you recall, every time we generated
a route it updated the router,
created a template for that route and
created a new route file.
In addition to everything
else routes do in Ember,
they're also in charge of
loading the data for that route.
The data, or model, is set or
fetched by this route file.
Let's update our app to
not use static html, but
instead use dynamic data
set by the route file.
When the URL is /menu,
this line matches.
It calls the menu route and
loads the menu template.
This is what a default
route file looks like.
Some things that are important are that
we have access to the Ember object,
up here, and that when this file is used
the Ember route class is extended
with an object that we can customize.
A bunch of things happen when a route
is loaded, and Ember gives us specially
named functions that we can use to
hook into these specific events.
Ember gives us a number of different
hooks that we can use in a route file.
One of the most important hooks we
can use to gain access to the loading
of new data is model.
This hook is responsible for
returning the model or data.
Remember what's being
returned is an object.
If this syntax looks weird, it's the
newer style of JavaScript to write this.
Since Ember lives on the freshest
version of JavaScript,
I'll stick with Ember's standards and
keep my route hooks like this.
I've extracted the data for
the menu items into a json
file in the public folder.
This file is available
in the instructor notes.
Now, we can use the model hook
to retrieve this data file.
The Ember object has j query
aliased to the dollar, so
we can use j query to get the file.
Because this is the route model,
the data in the template is
stored in a model variable.
There's a handlebars helper log that
we can use to log out a variable.
Here's that object
logged to the console.
And here are the three menu
items with their data.
Now that we have dynamic data set from
the route, let's update the static
template with expressions
that will evaluate this data.
First we can get rid of these two and
leave just this one list
item's HTML structure.
Then let's use that each
helper to loop over the model.
Now it's just updating the static
text with their dynamic counterparts.
These two will change to item.name.
The image here is item.image and
the link will use the item's ID.
Everything still looks the same but
now it's being dynamically fetched and
displayed.
Great work.